Tim Poole is a journalist who has
covered conflicts in Egypt Ukraine
Venezuela and many other countries
actually caught a video of his yesterday
that he uploaded from Milwaukee and I
wanted to have him on the show just to
kind of give us an update on what's
going on in Milwaukee and actually why
he left Milwaukee so Tim how you doing
pretty good
great thanks for having me on yeah my
pleasure so truth be told I did not know
of your work until yesterday but I saw
that video popped up in my Twitter feed
and it was it was pretty scary what you
were talking about so before we get to
that for the people that don't know
what's going on in Milwaukee right now
can you give like a two minute breakdown
of what has transpired to lead us to
where we're at at the moment yes it's
very similar to Ferguson Baltimore and
now we're seeing the same things in
Milwaukee there was a police shooting of
a man excuse me and you know the details
surrounding the the shooting of you know
of this man Sylvia Smith are cloudy
because the the city hasn't released any
information on this but what we can say
is you know following this man's death
you know the police are saying he was
armed and the officer shot him was black
the the community in Milwaukee
immediately took to protesting and
eventually writing they burned down six
businesses four officers were injured
there was gunshots back and forth I
believe 17 arrests that night and and
that's when I you know I went down there
because this is this is kind of my beat
you know not particularly the black
lives matter protests or you know this
writing stuff but you know I typically
cover conflicts that are having a
serious impact on politics and the world
and so the other night being down there
on the ground what we ended up seeing
was it wasn't as heated as the first
night we saw just bricks bricks being
thrown like crazy in the air police you
know guarding against them we saw white
people were being attacked and this is
you know with what the video that I put
I was about and it called him it
culminated to the extreme with an 18
year old white man being shot in the
neck yeah okay so just to recap what you
said there so some of the
evidence of what's coming out we just
don't know all the facts yet but it was
a black officer that shot him and he was
armed we know that much but in a way
that's all sort of secondary to now what
is happening because it's almost like
well I guess this is a bad pun but
gasoline has been poured on the fire now
and it sounds pretty lawless what's
going on there well I think you know
it's calmed down quite a bit you know
last night I had left so I'm not there
anymore I'm back come back home in Miami
but it doesn't seem nearly as heated as
it was I think what's what's becoming I
guess concerning is more of the
political rhetoric around these protests
so you know not so much that they've
continued to burn down the city I mean
there was a car that was lit on fire the
other day but so much as the the scent
the racial sentiment as you know it used
to be more directed towards police as an
institution and the idea of the
historical oppression that you know has
grown from the systemic racism but now
it's more just race right okay so let's
get to that because that's what your
video you did about a five-minute video
will link to it right down below and
basically you were saying it that you've
been all over the world you've covered
all kinds of conflicts and this was the
one where you actually felt the most
threatened I mean you've been to Egypt
during the revolution you've been to
Ukraine and as well and many other
places and this was the one and
basically I mean you heard people
calling to to kill white people and all
kinds of really horrible stuff well this
isn't the one I had actually had to flee
Venezuela and but when we're looking at
other countries that the fighting is
between specific factions for specific
reasons not so much based on your race I
mean there there's always racial issues
and you know like Egypt and all that
stuff but in Milwaukee people were
screaming [ __ ] white people they were
screaming white people suck I watched a
reporter get smacked upside the head and
then this woman's are going around
saying let's get em come on everybody
let's go let's get them and I actually
had to back up and you know I'm like
this is okay you know I got to be
careful and I mentioned this in the
I'm actually part Korean and you know
but I think you know one of the things I
saw there was a man who was screaming
about how Latinos Asians and whites
wouldn't exist were it not for the for
the blacks from Africa and they were
generally it seemed that they were more
generalizing people who were not black
as sort of the anger but you know I will
say the sentiment was definitely towards
you know they were angry like [ __ ] white
people right so it was targeted towards
white people and it just got to the
point where you know we heard gunshots
and you know I've been around gunshots
it's I know how to I know how to act I
know how to be safe but when I saw that
it was a young young man you know
holding his neck and the police had to
come in with their rifles up you know
flashlights pointed down gangways it was
like watching some kind of scary action
movie as their scream like move move
move and they're extracting this kid who
got shot in the neck and and that's when
I thought you know look if they don't
want us here then we shouldn't be here
right and if it's if it's dangerous for
dangerous for me to be here I shouldn't
be here either
yeah that must not be an easy decision
for you to make as a journalist someone
that prides herself on being on the
ground and all that I mean was it just
clear like once you saw that moment was
that just enough or did you kind of
struggle with the decision to even do it
I mean it was a buddy of mine we saw you
know I saw someone lift this kid up onto
their shoulder and rushed them in a
building and I didn't exactly know
what's happening but later you know a
few minutes later we see this kid
sitting on the on the porch when the
police rush in and I see him holding his
neck and not entirely sure what's
happening other than someone got hurt
and people get hurt all the time but it
was couple minutes after that we heard
that was the shooting victim being
extracted and that's when I you know I
thought this is getting pretty serious
yeah and then actually upon leaving we
got reports that automatic gunfire had
gone off back in the direction we had
left and so you know me and my you know
one of my buddies is a great disaster
conflict reporter and we both said we're
calling it and we left and it was later
that night where I decided you know what
I have to leave yeah how difficult is it
for you guys when you're in the heat of
the battle there to cover this stuff I
was watching you know the mainstream
media of course I think it's totally
dropping the ball on this we're barely
seeing any of the stuff that we're
seeing on periscope and on Facebook
video and all that kind of stuff
I saw some videos I saw the things about
you know kill white people and and
throwing bricks and stuff like that but
I saw videos of a group of people right
in cops faces the cops just standing
there not not provoking anyone now of
course I don't know what happened you
know 10 seconds before the video started
but I saw the conscious in and people
just in their face screaming at them you
know keep approaching keep approaching
keep approaching what do you think as
someone that's been there what do you
think the cops are supposed to do in an
instant like that it's so it's so
challenging I mean protesters and riders
and you know when you see these angry
people get up in cops faces it's very
very common
you know we I've seen it at some of the
smallest protests and some of the
largest and you know even in civil war
it's always difficult because what ends
up happening is when the police react to
this anger you know when they move in
when they make arrests it could just
make the situation worse it could make
the community much more angry but the
inverse is also a problem they do
nothing then we see buildings burnt down
and so it's just it's as dangerous
double edged sword that's extremely hard
to defuse I mean honestly I don't I
don't know how to solve that problem
yeah so I sense that you're you're
sympathetic to what the original black
lives movement seemed to be about you
were covering it as you said from from
the beginning it seems to me that
something has changed here where either
the movement has lost some leadership
and now it's almost like you know the
it's being run by individual people or
individual actions as opposed to
something you know top-down did you
agree with that assessment yeah I think
you know it's it's it's become very it's
been a very large movement and there's a
bunch of you know independent people who
are sort of taking things upon
themselves in the in the beginning you
mentioned being sympathetic I you know
in the beginning was very much directed
towards police accountability mm-hmm and
you know my stance is you know I a group
on the south side chicago man and I've
dealt with a lot of issues with police
not being held accountable for breaking
policy and breaking the law so seeing
that stuff you know to an extent I'm
definitely sympathetic but you know as a
whole I try to hold individuals
accountable for actions of entire groups
so it was something I you know leaned in
- but as of lately with with what we saw
in in IIE you know correct me if I'm
wrong but I think in Orlando a black
lives matter group took over the stage
at the Orlando shooting memorial and and
criticized white people and demanded
money yeah we've seen a bunch of we saw
it up at the Toronto Gay Pride thing
where they did something similar yeah it
seems like it's it's not so much about
the police brutality anymore and the
institutions that are perceived as
racist but just about more race and and
I think the alarming thing for me and
one of the things I contribute to my
decision to leave we're friends of mine
who are not white who are Latino the
Puerto Rican and Hispanic who are some
of the biggest proponents of the black
lives matter protests telling me not to
be there and to leave because it's no
longer about that anymore and you know I
had people texting me like crazy being
like you if you're going to be there you
need full armor this is you know and
it's crazy because these are the people
that were were fighting on the ground on
the front lines of the black lives
matter protest since Trayvon Martin now
telling me to leave and that was
definitely a big contributor to why I
said you know what the I should yeah I
mean it's it's just incredible and
that's why I wanted to have you on what
do you make of how the mainstream media
covers this stuff because as I said
before we're barely seeing any of this
stuff I do watch CNN as much as I hate
it and they're just not given us much
and I have to turn to people I'm glad I
found you but now we're turning to
online people digital people to give us
the news that the mainstream just
doesn't do did you see the CNN video has
been going viral that CNN edited one at
the vigil the sister of Silva was
speaking and they added a segment to
where she just says don't bring the
violence here and they cut but what she
actually said was bringing to the
suburbs and burn that down yeah I saw I
didn't see the CNN version of that I saw
the full version of that yeah yeah I
mean that damn yeah it's crazy and and
the other crazy thing is when I when I
put this video out you know I did not
expect it to get attention I thought you
know here's the issue I have a decent
amount of followers who come to me for
breaking news and if I have roughly left
they would be confused and not only that
I'd probably I would be criticized for
not covering an important story I'd say
people people would be saying to me like
oh you're refusing to go into the
poor neighborhoods to cover the story so
I felt you know let me let me come out
and talk about it but what really
surprised me is that a huge swath of
people said I don't believe you that
this 18 year old this young young man
was shot and I started looking all over
the web to try and find information
about it and you see one or two
sentences an 18 year old man receiving
it on non-life-threatening injuries and
a gun shake it would do to a shooting
and they that they don't go into it at
all and so I actually went to one of my
buddies who filmed it and I said why
isn't you know no one's reporting this
someone was shot in the neck this is
serious I have no idea why and you know
so I shared the video and the video got
a decent amount of shares on my across
my social network with people commenting
saying I didn't know this happened and
still I still get people saying if it
actually happened why isn't the media
reporting on it and that really scares
me yeah I mean that's doubly scary
because then it's like you're out there
doing the real work and now somehow your
authenticity is challenged because
you're showing the [ __ ] that that
they're not shown in the first place
well it's um and I appreciate you doing
this on such short notice and I'd be
happy to have you on again next time
you're out in the field or want to
report on anything because you're
obviously doing good work and I
appreciate it so everyone can check out
your YouTube channel it's youtube.com
slash Tim casts and link to the original
video is right down below
you